انه زمن الاسود وان كان للمتادور اعتاد
ترويض الثيران وتركيعها فاين للاسود كلاما
اخر انها فرحه انها معجزه ربما والاكيد
انها التاريخ ببساطه فريق عربي في الثماني
النهائي لمونديال يقام ايضا للمره الاولى
في العالم العربي شوط اول خال من الاهداف
ثم الثاني ثم الاضافي الاول والاضافه
الثانيه وفي النهايه لحظه الحقيقه ضربات
الترجيح ابتسم الليث واسم ذلك الليث حارس
المرمى ضد ضربتين وساعدته العارضه في
الثالثه لحظات تاريخيه للنساءها جيل كامل
نعود الى تلك اللحظه
الغيبه
[موسيقى]
هذه ارقام ومعلومات تختصر المباراه
التاريخيه للمغرب في مواجهه اسبانيا وطبعا
اولها ان المغرب هو اول منتخب عربي يحضر
في الدوري بعد النهائي بتاريخ كاس العالم
المغرب اول منتخب عربي قدره 3 الترجيح
بالتاريخ كاس العالم وهو اول منتخب عربي
يحافظ على نظافه الشباكيه في ثلاث مباريات
موندياليه بنسخه واحده وفي الارقام
القياسيه ايضا المغرب اول منتخب عربي يقضي
اربع مباريات من دون خساره في مونديال
واحد اما اسبانيا المونديال بركلات
الترجيح المره الثانيه على التوالي وهي
تخسر برجله الترجيح للمره الرابعه في
تاريخها والاسف ركله الترجيح الاسبانيه
الاولى صدمت بالعارضه
لكان حارس المنتخب المغربي ياسين بونو اول
حارس في التاريخ يتصدى لثلاث ركلات ترجيح
متتاليه بالتاريخ كاس العالم وهي
بالمناسبه خساره المؤسفه في عالم الارقام
[موسيقى]
عالميه
امشي بركاس العربيه يا الله ويالا
لي
وتنسنيتي ماشي عادي وهذا شكون يسجل عليه
قالوا اولاد بلادي
من الدوحه ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
نايف الثقيل صباح الخير يا نايف في
الاستوديو ينضم لان الاعلام الرياضي منير
رحوم اهلا بك يا منير وكذلك زميل العزيز
محمد الطميحي يبقى معي الفرحه
العربيه السعوديه تونسيه جزائريه من كل
مكان ومن الضفره
باي مناسبه لها علاقه بالاحتفالات وباي
فوز عربي تذكر المره الاولى كانت فوز
المنتخب السعودي والله الان انا موجود
فرحان بفوز المنتخب
المدينه التاريخ
اهلا سهام واهلا بضيوفك طبعا الى يعني
ساعات الصباح الاولى والدوحه تحتفل
بانتصار تاريخي للمنتخب المغربي
طبعا دعينا نتحدث عن ما قبل المباراه كان
هناك احتجاج بالاف الجماهير المغربيه
والجماهير العربيه في محيط الملعب قد تكون
هذه المباراه الاولى التي تشهد هذا التجمع
الكبير من الجماهير يعني حتى الطفت اللجنه
المنظمه الاستدعاء عناصر اضافيه
لضبط الوضع في المنطقه المحيطه همم الكل
كان يرغب ان يدخل الى المدرجات والكل كان
لديه ثقه كبيره بالمنتخب المغربي اثناء
المباراه يعني كانت همم
الاوضاع مشدوده والاعصاب مشدوده بسبب يعني
وصوله الى الاشواط
الاضافيه ولكن بعد المباراه كان هناك
الاحتفال الكبير وانا كنت داخل مع
الجماهير وشاهد تعريف
لا توصف داخل المدرجات وايضا حتى احتفالات
اللاعبين في منطقه المكزون في المختلطه
بعد المباراه يعني التقيت بمعظم اللاعبين
المنتخب المغربي كانوا سعيدين همم جدا
بهذه الانتصاب وقد يكون يعني اللغه نوعا
ما تغيرت والطموحات ارتفعت الجميع يتحدث
عن نصف النهائي وانه
سيكون لهم بصمه في همم المباراه المقبله
وسل لن يتنازلوا عن الوصول الى نصف
النهائي كاول المنتخب عربي في التاريخ يصل
الى نصف النهائي بعد ان كسر الرقم فيه
النهائي طيب منير
يعني المغرب صراحه امس دون اسمه باحرف من
ذهب على الساحر المستطيله يعني فوز تاريخي
هو الاول العربي بركلات الترجيح على
اسبانيا يعني بطلت كاس العالم 2010 كيف
تقيمك لهذا طبعا صباح السعاده لانه فوز
المنتخب المغربي ادخل السعاده في كل
البيوت العربيه وحتى همم خارج الدول
العربيه في اوروبا شفنا بالامس يعني
الافراح كل العرب بصفه عامه اكيد المنتخب
المغربي لاول مره فنشعر في يعني كعرب اننا
نمره منتخب قادر على الفوز بكاس العالم
ببساطه يعني دائما كنا ندخل كاس العالم من
همم يعني بشعار المشاركه المشرفه لا اليوم
نملك منتخب بللامانه قادر على المنافسه
وقادر على مقارعه المنتخبات الكبرى شاهدنا
يعني الاداء امام منتخب كرواتيا كان جيدا
شاهدنا الفوز على بلجيكا شاهدنا الفوز على
اسبانيا اليوم الطموحات كبيره الاحلام
اصبحت حقيقه على فكره شعار كاس العالم همم
الحاليون اليوم على ارض عربيه نحن
نحلموس الفوز بكاس العالم او على الاقل
الوصول الى ابعد ما يمكن في هذه البطوله
طموحات وبس نحن نتحدث هنا عن فريق استطاع
تحقيق انتصارات متتاليه يتصدر مجموعته
ويمتلك عدد كبير من النجوم المحترفين اللي
حققه الفوز الانديتهم الاوروبيه والعالميه
التالي المسر ربما تتجاوز الطموحات الى
واقع يتمثل في قدره فريق عربي متكامل على
تحقيق نتائج المتقدمه ليس هنا فقط وانما
ايضا في المباراه المقبله امام البرتغال
ماذا نتوقع محمد يعني حتى بالارقام
المنتخب المغربي يعني يساوي المنتخبات
التي وصلت لدور الثمانيه اقوى خط دفاع في
هذه البطوله يعني شاهدنا تالق عدد كبير من
النجوم وحتى في غياب بعض العناصر بسبب
الاصابه او عدم جهازياتهم مثلا مثلا اشرف
حكيمي شارك وهو يعني يعاني من بعض الام
لكن في النهايه شاهدنا منتخب تكتيكيا قوي
وجيد اداء على اللياقه والاداء البدني
ممتاز جدا وفي النهايه اداء بطوله منتخب
وبنفس الروح انا متفائل ان هذا المنتخب
سوف يكون في المربع الذهبي
صح فقعدنا تكون المباراه لابد طبعا قبل
المباراه وبعض المباراه لابدي يذهب لاخذ
بركات امه وكان هو الذي حقق هدف الفوز
ضربا الاخيره التي نفذها باحترافيه كبيره
جدا ثم المسيره طويله لهذا الشاب المغربي
الذي شارك في انديه عالمي محمد هذه
اللمسات العربيه في كاس العالم يعني لا
نشاهد اللاعبين الاوروبيين يعني
كتبونداتهم او يعني لابائهم واسارهم عاده
خلال يعني المباريات هذه يعني لمسات عربيه
عفت المزيد من الارتباط العاطفي بلاعبي
يعني المنتخبات العربيه الذين يشاركون في
هذه الكاس العالم وخاصه المنتخب المغربي
الذي يعني بصراحه كان متميزا ومتالقا داخل
الملعب وخارج الملعب طيب
المباراه المدرب المغربي مصطفى بركه السيد
مصطفى يعني النسخه الثانيه على التوالي
تعجز اسبانيا على الفوز على المغرب يعني
ماضي كان تعادل اثنين واثنين هالمره
المغرب فازت باكلات الترجيح شو هي عناصر
القوه لدى المنتخب المغربي لجعلته عصيا
كاول منتخب عربي على اسبانيا
همم تحياتي استاذتها للحضور كريم همم اكيد
هذه فرحه عريمه يعني بعد هذا الانتصار
تاريخي للمغرب وكذلك هو انتصار للدول
العربيه والفرق العربيه
الحمد لله على هذا
المستوى اللي يقدموا همم المنتخب المغربي
هذا حلم يعني صار لنا زمان نحن في المحل
وكيف همم
يعني الدول العربيه لما تدخل الكاس العالم
فهي يعني همم يعني كانها للمشاركه بس يعني
الدور الاول اغلى في الفرق بتطلع لكن انا
المغرب اليوم كان همم عنده واحد تحدي
كبير وتحدي يعني باطار وطني
اطار وطني همم كابتن همم الرجاله يجيء
يعمل واحد همم واحد تولي ما بين شباب وما
بين همم لاعبي الخبره
وحصلنا على فريق اللي عنده الروح روح
للانضباط روح
للوطنيه نروح العروبه يعني كابتن بما انك
تحدثت عن المدرب رجالي همم عندما تعطى هذه
الثقه لمدرب لوطني ويحقق انجازات كبيره
بهذا المستوى كيف نعكس عنكم عليكم ايضا
انتم همم كمدربين وطنيين فيما يتعلق ليس
بالايمان بالله فقط وانما ايضا بالمقدرات
التي يمتلكها المدرب العرب
هو في الحقيقه لما يكون عندك اطار وطني
وهو اللي بيمسك الفريق يعني المنتخب فهذا
بحد ذاته حافز للاطرمه الوطنيه
سواء العربيه او المغربيه واحنا لما تتكلم
عن المغربي يعني هذا اعطى حافظ للقطور
المغربيه انه في امل انه اي واحد اي واحد
اشتغل يعني اي مد
رب
اللي يوصل
الكابتن وليد ولكن احنا ربما كان في بين
قوسين لان حتى الوقت اللي وصل فيه وليد
للمنتخب يعني
شهرين او ثلاث شهور على كاس العالم بعد
المشاكل اللي كانت ندى كانت تحدي تحدي
كبير وربما همم يعني 50% 50% انه الناس
ال- ال- المتتبعين كانوا يشققون في ان هذا
الفريق او
سيصل الى هذه المستوى اللي وصل لي الحين
ولكن الحمد لله يعني همم الخبره بتاع هذا
المدرب الشاب لانه هذا مدرب كيف تعرفه انه
لاعب منتخب قديم يعني سابق هو انه يعني
دربك في الوداد وحاسه
وحصل على البطوله الوطنيه وكذلك لما كان
في الفتح ولكن
يعتبر رجل المباراه يعني هل بالفعل يمكن
اعتبار كذلك في ظل التصدي الثلاث ركلات
ترجيح
يعني ربما هذا التصدي
ما يحصل الا بال حراس الكبار وثلاثه انا
وهذا مسيرته
الدوري الاسباني وانه اخيرا كان حصل على
على جائزه جائزه مهمه امام كورتوا يعني
همم الحارس يعني يكتبوا له حسابه انك هلا
عشان تحصل انك تصدى لثلاث درجات
يعني مش بالصدفه انه اصلا حارس حارس ما
شاء الله في المستوى العالم
مين المغرب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كدا رقراق اللي
خلاني
[موسيقى]
فرحانه
بالزكان زوينه وباقي زوين
بروكو ان شاء الله ناخدوا الكاس العالم
علاش
[تصفيق]
فرحانه فرحانه فرحانه بزاف
قوي بزاف
[موسيقى]
عليهم
تبارك الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مغربيه
كاس العربيه يا الله ويالا
لي
ماشي عادي وهذا شلون بلادي
[موسيقى]
عبد
الاله
[موسيقى]
بيني وبينكم وجع خسرته 89
رقصات مغربيه
تعبان وسهله
على الصعيد الشخصي من اجمل لحظات ال ال
الرياضيه التي عشتها كانت بالامس بعد
نهايه المباراه يعني علامات الفضاء على
جميع وجوه الجمهور العربي والجمهور
المغربي واحتفالات ان كانت جدا يعني تسعد
اي شخص ينظر الى هذا المنظر لكن دعيني
سهام اتحدث عن جوانب اخرى يعني قد تعزز
حديث زملاء الضيوف قبل قليل فيما يخص
دوبات الجزاء والبعض يستغرب انه المنتخب
الاسباني يعني اخطاء في تسجيل ضربات
الجزاء في المقابل نجاح المنتخب المغربي
اعتقد هذا الامر يعود الى تعامل المدربين
مع هذا الموقف هناك تناقض كبير بين
المنتخب الاسباني المنتخب امس في خلال
حديث مع اللاعبين ذكره اللاعبين المنتخب
لم يطلب منهم اي تدريبات اضافيه او جماعيه
خلال الحصص التدريب على ضربات الجزاء هو
ذكر لهم ان يثق يثق في اللاعبين وقدراتهم
على تسجيل ضربات الجزاء وان من يرى في
نفسه الحاجه اللي اداه تدريبات اضافيه
يقوم بشكل انفرادي ايضا حتى الحارس تحدث
الاهل المدرب بهذا الامر في المقابل مدرب
اسبانيا الزم اللاعبين كل لاعب سدد 1000
ضربه جزاء تدرب على 1000 ضربه جزاء ولكن
المحصله النهائيه كانت
ولا ولا ضربه همم تسجيلها ايضا حتى
لاحظتنا وتحدثت مع اللاعبين في هذه النقطه
عند اختيار من سيسدد ضربات الجزاء في
المنتخب المغربي يعني قد تكون من الحالات
النادره ان يكون مدافع بالاجتماع بلاعبيه
ويترك المساحه لهم ليختاروا من سيبدا همم
ضربات الجزاء كان يرفع اصبعه برقم واحد
يقوم واحد للاعبين بالمباده انا ما انسى
اسدد بعدين يرفع الرقم اثنين وثلاثه
واربعه وخمسه تواكل الحوثي للاعبين من
داخل لانه جاهز
لاحوازف او همم
تحقيق الضفه الصحيحه يتقدم لاداء هذا
التعامل جدا احترافي من المدرب دعيني ايضا
نتحدث عن جانب القتاليه في همم اللاعبين
وهذا انعكاس كبير سفيان مرابط ليله
المباراه كان يعاني من اصابه وابلغ انه
سيستبعد من المباراه لاعب انضلي التي يبكي
وذهبي للمدرب وطلب منه ان يستخدم تحت
الاشراف الطبي ببعض المسكنات التي ساعده
على المشاركه في المباراه اخذ المسكنات
ذهب الى المستشفى واخد المسكنات ما هي
المحصله سهام هو اكثر لاعب في المباراه
طوال ال120 دقيقه جراء داخل ارضيه الملعب
رغم الاصابه رغم ان يلعب في المشكلات ايضا
جميع الالتحامات وجميع التدخلات كانت
ناجحه بنسبه 100% رغم الاصابه فهذا يعطيك
جانب بسيط من القتاليه ووح العاليه اللي
يتمتع فيها لاعبي المنتخب المغربي وانه
وصولهم لرفع النهائي ليس محفظ الصدفه
وانما يعني خفايا وكواليس موجوده داخل
المعسكر والمغرب قد كنا يعني كشفنا طيب
منير الدور ربع النهائي هو الاول تاريخيا
للمغرب الاول في تاريخ ورصيده الرياض هو
الاول عربيا وهو الرابع افريقا بعد غانا
الكاميرون والسينغال صح اهميه ذلك عربيا
وتاريخيا في المنطقه طبعا اليوم المنتخب
المغربي امام كتابه تاريخ جديد للكره
العربيه والافريقيه يعني حجم كبير جدا
يعني بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي ان شاء الله
يعني ينجح في تحقيق هذا المنتخب
يعني اختفت الضغط
اليوم موجود في ربع النهائي لاول مره وهذا
يعني طبعا طبعا
مثلا
البدايه المنتخب السعودي داخل المباراه
الاولى بدون ضغوط
بعد الفوز على الارجنتين ارتفع سقف
التوقعات كان الناس يطالب بادوار متقدمه
وصارت الهزائم فيما بعد الضغوط زادت
هل المساله مثل الضغوط على المنتخب
المغربي ام ان هذا ضغوط ولدت ثقه خاصه
بانه زي ما ذكرنا كان في انجازات مستمره
مش مباراه واحده
اتكلم تقريبا عن 54 مرايا لا محمد اكيد
انا بنتفق معك يعني في هذه النقطه لكن
خلينا يعني نقطه مهمه اخرى انه الاغلب
اللاعبين المنتخب
يعني تراكمات مخبره وتجارب ومباريات
مضغوطه وهو يعني
استحقاقات كبرى عالميه اشرف حكيمي كان
يلعب في ريال مدريد واليوم في باريس سان
جيرمان
حتى في المنتخب السعودي في محترفين كبار
مستوى العالم هذا ما كان ينقص اللاعب
السعودي فقط
التميز بصراحه انجازات الحلقه نعم فوز على
الارجنتين فوز تاريخي وحتى النتائج ما
كانت مخيبه الامل بشكل كبير
احتراف من لعيبه المنتخب السعودي اللي
تميزوا خلال المونديال في اوروبا
على الاقل في الانديه اوروبيه محترمه لكن
المشكله محمد وانت عارف اكثر مني
المسؤوليه الانديه السعوديه الذين يريدون
التشبه باللهب ولا يعني يمنحوه فرصه
الاحتراف الاوروبي فهي يعني
اتمنى اتمنى جدا محمد لانه الاحتراف
الخارجي سوف يقدم الكثير الكره السعوديه
والخليجيه عثر على اداء المنتخب المغربي
اليوم الذي وصل الى مرحله متطوره جدا
ويقار على الانديه الاوروبيه فاعتقد انا
لا خوف على الضغوطات محمد في هذه النقطه
وانا متفائل ان يكون الاداء بنفس ما
شاهدناه متتاليه
يعني يعرف عن المنتخب الاسباني تمسكه
بالكره ودفاع القوي هل هذا ما منع المغرب
امس من تسجيلاته
والله هي في الحقيقه يعني
المباراه
واسبانيا يعني عرفت يعني عرفات اشياء
اشياء كثيره
تفتح الملعب في وجهها واحد الطريق
لنتمكن من من قدراته فاكيد هتفتح شوارع
وهذا همم غير ايجابي بالنسبه للمنتخب
المغربي في حين اننا شفنا المنتخب كان
مسكره يعني الممرات ممرات التمرير
وبالتالي همم حصلنا على على وحده البلوك
يعني اللي خلانا اننا مستقبلش الاهداف في
في الاصوات الاولى وهذا الشيء يشجع
اللعيبه خاصه اول لما خلص
المحاولات اللي همم
لربما لو لو كان تكون شيء ثاني لا لا لا
يعني لا ننسى انه همم هذه كانه مباراه
لانه في همم 2018 كان عندنا مباراه على
المنتخب الاسباني وكذلك حصلناه نتيجه
النتيجه
التعادل اثنين اثنين همم
دي المساري طيب
فيعني كان هذا تحدي لا انا نحن ك- اا
المنتخب المغربي كابتن مصطفى على قدر
التحدي سؤال الاهم الان هل نحن همم
مستعدون همم للمنتخب البرتغالي هل تتوقع
بان تستمر احنا ما نتحدث عن تمنيات بس
احنا نتحدث اهل عن توقعات هل ستستمر هذه
همم او هذا الزخم الذي حصل عليه المنتخب
المغربي خلال مباريات الماضيه ان نتوقع
بان يستفيد المغرب من ربما ما يقال لتخلخل
في خط الهجوم همم البرتغالي بوجود رونالدو
احيانا في مقاعد الاحتياطها ان نتوقع
استمرار النتائج الايجابيه للمنتخب
المغربي
اكيد اكيد هذا هو هدفونا هو هذا هو طموحنا
فا
كل متتبع لما دخل المنتخب المغربي الى هذه
الاقصائيات او هذه النهائيه كاس العالم
فما كان يعطي نسبه واحد نسبه اننا ممكن
نمرض دور ثاني فبالتالي لما احنا مرينا
بدور ثانيه والحين احنا في الربع النهائي
فهد شيء جميل فهذا طموح طموح مستحق وامال
الشعب المغربي الدول العربيه اننا نصل الى
احد حتى اقصى فلم البرتغال لان حتى
البرتغال في 2018 كان معنا همم يعني كلنا
نهزمنا معهم وكان رونالدو هولي سجل اظن
الهدف الثاني فاكيد هيكون هناك ردت فعل
ولكن دائما انا المغرب ما عنده ما يخسر
ممكن البرتغال عنده شيء تخسره اسبانيا عند
تخسره الارجنتين كذا وكذا ولكن فريق طموح
فريق شاب فريق بيبحث على على افاق يبحث
على على على قرض ذاته فاكيد ما عندناش اي
نقطه احنا وصلنا
لهذا المستوى فهذا يكفينا ولكن طموح يبقى
غالي على كل لاعب انه يصلي اوديوم وان شاء
الله
البرتغال لما لا يعني عندكم استراتيجيه
ثانيه مع كابتن وليد الركراكي ستراتيجيه
ثانيه ربما فريق البرتغال واش هو فريق
الاسباني ولكن هنحاول ان شاء الله تكون
عندنا يعني بودر ثانيه عشان ربما
الاقصى حد في هذه البطوله ان شاء الله
ولماذا ههه
من المغرب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اسمع اسمع
[تصفيق]
مباراه المغرب البرتغال توقعاتك
انا متفائل طبعا لكن بنفس الاداء اذا لم
تسجل اصابات سهام وليد الرجراجي قادر على
ايقاف المنتخب البرتغالي يملك الاسلحه
المناسبه لتحقيق لتطبيق التكتيك
وباذن الله اتوقع ان المنتخب المغربي سوف
يتجاوز هذه المنتخب البرتغالي طيب يا
كابتن مصطفى كابتن يعني السبت مباراه
السبت يعني عندهم هداف كريستيانو رونالدو
البرتغال لا تتوقع نفس تكتيك دفاعا للمغرب
ولكن احنا اللي نتمنى انه المغرب يظهر في
المستوى
[موسيقى]
احسن ويكون يعني تكون شكل نهج يعني ربما
هجومي
مش هو همم
[موسيقى]
مساله الاستخوان ولكنه رغما وجود رونالدو
خلاص احنا الحين لازم اي فريق يتكلم على
المغرب يعني لا لا برتغال ولا اي مكان
نتكلم عن المغرب
يعني جيد وانها اول فريق لا يسجل عليه الا
اصابه واحده في اربع مباريات
اجنحه حارس مرمى اللي في المستوى عندنا
زياش لزياج اللي قدم مستوى افضل المزراوي
حكيمي يعني لاعبه
ينشطونا في الدوريات الاوروبيه ربما عندهم
القدره وعندهم شجاعه انهم يواجهوا اي فريق
والحمد لله احنا الحين عندنا امل اننا
نمشي والابعد نقطه
للفريق همم المنتخب المغربي
كل التوفيق لاسود الاطلس محمد
بعد خروج كل المنتخبات العربيه عند
المنتخب المغربي هناك الكثير من الاعمال
على المنتخب المغربي
وبالتالي العشر ارتفع وصرحه ما راح نقبل
باقل من الفوز على
البرتار امر متاح صحيح
وان شاء الله نشوف همم
المنتخب المغربي متقدم ما هو تفاعل هذا
عشم
وكما توقعت الفوز في المنتخب في المباراه
الماضيه اتوقع ايضا فوزه في المباراه
المقبله وبفارق هدف
واتذكره كاس العالم يوم الاحد
شكرا
جزيلا بوجودك معنا
ونايف ثقيل من الدوحه شكرا جزيلا لكم
نورتونا